we now study a model that involves the
sum of independent random variables but
with a twist it's going to be the sum of
a random number of independent random
variables as opposed to a fixed number
this is a model that shows up in a
variety of applications but it will also
help us fine tune our command of the law
of iterated expectations and the law of
total variance the story goes as follows
you go shopping and you visit a number
of stores except that the number of
stores that you will visit is itself a
random variable at each one of the
stores you spend a certain amount of
money we denoted by X I and we make the
assumption that the x i's are drawn from
a certain distribution they're
identically distributed and they're
independent of each other
we also make the assumption that the x
i's are independent of capital and this
means that no matter how many stores you
visit the X I the amount of money you
spend in each one of the stores that you
visit is a random variable that's drawn
from a common distribution which does
not change no matter what capital n is
with these assumptions in place let us
now focus on the total amount of money
that you are spending this is the sum of
random variables but with the extra
twist that the index goes up to capital
n which is itself a random variable how
do we deal with this situation
one approach that's always worth trying
when faced with a complicated problem is
to try to condition on some information
that will make the problem easier in
this case we can condition on the value
of capital n taking a fixed specific
value because in that case we will be
dealing with the sum of a finite number
of random variables where that number is
a fixed specific number and this is a
situation we have encountered before and
know how to deal with it
so let us get started let us calculate
the expected value of y if we condition
on the number of stars let's say for
example someone tells us that we visited
five stars then the expected value of y
is going to be the expected value of the
sum of the amount of money you spend in
each one of those five stores in our
instance it's that random variable
capital n but since I told you that
capital n takes a specific numerical
value this means that this instance of
capital n in the index of the summation
can be replaced by little n if I tell
you that capital n is equal to little n
then this number here capital n becomes
the same as little n here we use now the
assumption that capital n is independent
from the excise here we have the sum of
a fixed number of random variables all
of them are independent of capital n if
I give you some information on capital n
this does not change the distribution of
the x i's so the conditioning does not
affect the answer the conditional
expectation is going to be the same as
the unconditional expectation and now we
have the expected value of a sum of
random variables each one of them has a
common expectation let's denote it with
this notation this is the common
expected value of all the x i's and
we're adding n of them so we obtain n
times this expectation now let us apply
the total expectation theorem do we take
the familiar form of the total
expectation theorem and in here we can
plug in the expression that we have just
found which is n times expected value of
x now the expected value of x is just a
number and then we have this summation
here which we recognize to be just the
definition of the expected value of N
and so we come to the conclusion that
the expected amount of money that you
will be spending is equal to the
following product the expected number of
stores that you visit times the expected
amount of money that you will be
spending at each store this is a quite
plausible answer it makes sense on the
average the amount of money you spend is
equal to the average number of stores
times the average amount of money in
each store so it is intuitively what you
might expect on the other hand we know
that reasoning on the average does not
always give us the right answers so it's
important to corroborate this particular
formula by working out a mathematical
derivation now let us carry out the
second mathematical derivation using the
law of iterated expectations to use the
law of iterated expectations we need to
put our hands on this random variable
the abstract conditional expectation
what is this object it's a random
variable that takes this value whenever
capital n is equal to little n so it's
an object that takes this value whenever
capital n is equal to little n but that
object is the same as this random
variable because this is the random
variable that takes the value here when
capital n is equal to little n therefore
the abstract conditional expectation
takes this particular form here which we
can substitute inside this expectation
here and now notice that the expected
value of X is a constant so it can be
pulled outside this expectation and
we're left with the product of the
expected value of n times the expected
value of X so this completes the
derivation of the expected value of the
sum of a random number of random
variables